there's like a million things to ask I
almost don't want to get distracted by
the marginal cost of energy going to
zero because I have no idea what you're
talking about that is fascinating can I
give you the 30 seconds sure okay yes
okay so if you look inside of the two
most Progressive States the three most
Progressive States New York California
and Massachusetts a lot of left-leaning
folks a lot of people who believe in
climate science and climate change
the energy costs in those three states
are the worst they are in the entire
country and energy is compounding at
three to four percent per annum so every
decade to 15 years energy costs in these
states double in some cases and in some
months our energy costs are increasing
by 11 a month
but the ability to actually generate
energy is now effectively zero the cost
per kilowatt hour to put a solar panel
on your roof and a battery wall inside
your garage it's the cheapest it's ever
been these things are the most efficient
they they've ever been and so to acquire
energy from the Sun and store it for
your use later on literally is a zero
cost proposition so what's how do you
explain the gap between the cost going
great question
so this is the other side of regulatory
capture right you know we all fight to
build monopolies while there are
monopolies hiding in plain sight the
utilities are a perfect example there
are a hundred million homes in America
there are about 1700 Utilities in
America so they have captive markets
but in return for that captive Market
the law says need to invest a certain
amount per year in upgrading that power
line in changing out that turbine in
making sure you transition from coal to
wind or whatever
just as an example
upgrading power lines in the United
States over the next decade is a two
trillion dollar proposition
these 1700 organizations have to spend I
think it's a quarter of a trillion
dollars a year
just to change the power lines that is
why even though it costs nothing to make
energy you are paying double every five
every seven or eight years
its capex and Opex have a very brittle
old infrastructure it's like you trying
to build an app and being forced to
build your own Data Center and you say
but wait I just want to write to AWS I
just want to use gcp I just want to move
on
all that complexity is solved for me
and some law says no you can't you got
to use it so that's what consumers are
dealing with but it's also what
industrial and Manufacturing
organizations it's what we all deal with
so how do we get rid ourselves off this
old infrastructure that we're paying so
the thing that's happening today which I
think is
this is why I think it's the most
important Trend right now in the world
is that a hundred million homeowners
are each going to become their own
little power plant and compete with
these 1700 utilities
and that is the United States or
globally no just just deal with the
United States for a second because I
think it's easier to see here 100
million homes solar panel on the roof
and by the way just to make it clear the
sun doesn't need to shine right these
these panels now work where you have
these UV bands that can actually
extrapolate beyond the visible spectrum
so they're usable in all weather
conditions
and a simple system can support you
collecting enough power to not just run
your functional day-to-day life
but then to contribute what's left over
back into the grid
for Google's data center or Facebook's
data center where you get a small check
the cost is going to zero how obvious is
this to people you're making yourself
okay so because this is a pretty
profound prediction if the cost is
indeed go to zero
that I mean the compute the cost of
compute going to zero I can so the cost
to compute going to zero is can kind of
understand but the energy seems like a
radical prediction of yours well it's
just it's just naturally what's
happening right now now let me let me
give you a different way of explaining
this
if you look at any system there's a
really important thing that happens it's
what clay Christensen calls crossing the
chasm if you explained it numerically
here's how I would explain it to you Lex
if you introduce a disruptive product
typically what happens is the first
three to five percent of people are
these zealous Believers and they ignore
all the logical reasons why this product
doesn't make any sense
because they believe in the proposition
of the future and they buy it
the problem is at five percent if you
want the product to get to mass Market
you have one of two choices which is you
either bring the cost down low enough or
the feature set becomes so compelling
that even at a high price point an
example of the latter is the iPhone
the iPhone today the 14 iPhone cost more
than the original iPhone it's probably
doubled in price over the last 14 or 15
years but we view it as an essential
element of what we need in our daily
lives
it turns out that battery EVs and solar
panels are an example of the former
because people like President Biden with
all of these subsidies have now
introduced so much money for people
to just do this where it is a money
making proposition for a hundred million
homes
and what you're seeing as a result are
all of these companies
who want to get in front of that Trend
why because they want to own the
relationship with 100 million homeowners
they want to manage the power
infrastructure Amazon Home Depot Lowe's
you know you can just name the company
so if you do that and you control that
relationship
they're going to show you they're going
you know for example Amazon will
probably say if you're a member of prime
we'll stick the panels on your house for
free
we'll do all the work for you for free
and it's just a feature of being a
member of prime and we'll manage all
that energy for you it makes so much
sense and it is mathematically accretive
for Amazon to do that
it's not accretive
for the existing energy industry because
they get blown up
it's extremely accretive for peace and
prosperity
if you think the number of Wars we fight
over natural resources take them all off
the table if we don't need energy from
abroad
there's no reason to fight
you'd have to find a reason to fight
um meaning sorry there'd be a moral
reason to fight but the last number of
wars that we fought
uh were not as much rooted in Morality
as they were rooted in yeah it feels
like they're very much rooted in uh
conflict resources for over resources
energy specifically and then sorry just
the last thing I want to say I keep
interpreting apologies but the chips
all what what people want to say is that
you know now that we're at two and three
nanometer scale for typical kind of like
transistor Fab
we're done and you know forget about
transistor density forget about Moore's
Lots over and I would just say no look
at teraflops and really teraflops is the
combination of CPUs but much much less
important and really is the combination
of Asics so application specific ICS and
gpus
and so you put the two together I mean
if I gave you a billion dollars five
years from now
the amount of damage you could do
damaged in good way
in terms of you know building racks and
racks of gpus the kind of models that
you could build the training sets and
the data that you could consume to solve
a problem
it's it's enough to to do something
really powerful whereas today it's not
yet quite enough